teachers around the world generally
despise wikipedia given that wikipedia
isn't always the most reliable or
reputable source with that being said
though i think students around the world
would agree that wikipedia is a
lifesaver whether you're trying to look
up a simple equation or trying to cram
for your fluid mechanics test wikipedia
has got you covered and the truth is
while wikipedia may not have been the
most accurate in its early days nowadays
wikipedia is pretty darn accurate
moreover most wikipedia articles are
really good at citing all of their
sources whether that be textbooks or
news publications so you can easily
verify all the info on wikipedia and
cite the source material and let's not
forget wikipedia is not only free but
they don't want any ads or sponsorships
or affiliate marketing or any of that
it's basically completely run on
donations and unlike textbook publishers
wikipedia truly isn't in it for the
profit but who even created this gem of
a website and where are they today
taking a look back wikipedia was founded
by two men the first of which being
jimmy wales jimmy was born on august 7
1966 in huntsville alabama fun fact he
was born minutes before midnight so even
though he was technically born on august
7th his birth certificate ended up
saying august 8th that must be confusing
whenever someone asked for his birthday
anyway jimmy's father was a grocery
store manager and his mother along with
his grandmother ran a small private
school jimmy and his siblings would all
end up attending this private school
from a very young age jimmy was a
massive fan of reading which is probably
something that most of us can't relate
with when he was just 3 years old his
mother got him a world book encyclopedia
and as jimmy grew up he ended up reading
the book several times but this quickly
led him to stumble upon a shortcoming if
something was wrong in the encyclopedia
how would the information be updated of
course newer editions could just be
printed with the updated information but
encyclopedias were generally long-term
investments that cost well over a
thousand dollars so people weren't gonna
buy new encyclopedias on a regular basis
but they also wanted the most up-to-date
info
the most common solution for the
shortfall was stickers publishers would
send out correction stickers to
encyclopedia owners and owners could
cover up the original text with the
updated sticker over the years jimmy
stickered up his encyclopedia and this
was his first experience in revising an
encyclopedia but he wouldn't revisit
this experience for decades after
elementary school and middle school
jimmy attended a university preparatory
school called randolph school apparently
the school was rather expensive for his
family but they paid the bill anyway
because they highly valued education the
preparatory school allowed jimmy to
graduate a bit early at 16 and he would
end up attending auburn university where
he majored in finance after his
bachelor's jimmy tried pursuing a phd in
finance from the university of alabama
but he ended up with the masters in
finance instead he did give the phd one
more shot at indiana university but he
never wrote a doctoral thesis which he
claims was simply due to boredom with
all this education it wouldn't have been
surprising if jimmy jumped straight into
the world of encyclopedias but jimmy
actually entered the world of finance
in 1994 he got a job at chicago options
associates which was a futures and
options trading firm despite his career
in finance jimmy's true interest was
always within the internet he was a
massive fan of a game called the
multi-user dungeons and he regularly
moderated various online forms in other
words he was basically the modern day
discord moderator while discord mods
often get a lot of slack moderation was
actually quite beneficial for jimmy you
see it was while moderating an online
discussion group about philosophy that
jimmy would run into wikipedia's other
founder larry sanger
tequila looked back once again larry
sanger was born on july 16th 1968 in
bellevue washington his father worked as
a marine biologist while his mother was
a homemaker when he was just seven the
family moved to a rather unique location
which was anchorage alaska despite the
cool change of scenery larry's interest
didn't sway much like jimmy larry was
also a massive fan of reading and
especially learning about philosophy
following his interests larry would end
up attending the same college as steve
jobs read college where he majored in
philosophy aside from his interest in
philosophy larry was also super
intrigued by the internet he wasn't a
gamer or an online memer though he was
primarily intrigued by the internet's
potential to be used as a publishing
outlet you could reach millions if not
tens of millions of people through the
internet without having to spend
millions yourself on publishing
licensing and distribution
larry decided to put this theory to the
test during college by creating a
discussion forum that allowed students
to meet with tutors online in other
words he basically created the modern
day check so you got the discord mod and
the check founder and these two would
meet in 1994 when larry subscribed to
jimmy's mailing list called moderated
discussion of objectivist philosophy or
mdop the two quickly became friends and
had discussions about life and
philosophy here and there but neither of
them had the idea of starting a business
together so larry simply continued on in
his educational journey stacking on
degree after degree in 1995 harry earned
a masters in philosophy from ohio state
university and he would turn around and
also get a phd in philosophy from ohio
state in 2000. in the meantime larry
also ran a website called sanger and
shannon's review of y2k news reports
which was dedicated to discussing the
year 2000 problem if you're not familiar
with this it was basically the fear that
computers would glitch out and have a
bunch of errors as soon as the date
changed from 1999 to 2000. while there
were some errors here and there once we
hit 2000 nothing catastrophic unfolded
and the year 2000 problem ended up being
a big nothing burger larry's side never
really gained that much popularity in
the first place but even if it did it
wouldn't have mattered much given that
its popularity would have fallen off a
cliff once 2000 hit clearly larry wasn't
having much success with the internet
but the same it could not be said about
jimmy
unlike larry who likely didn't have too
much money to invest in internet
projects jimmy was stacked thanks to
wall street jimmy had correctly
speculated on fluctuations in interest
rates and foreign currencies for years
which made him quite a bit of money and
seeing the insanely successful ipo of
netscape in 1995 jimmy knew that he had
to invest all this money into an
internet project initially he launched a
search engine called bomis which was a
guy-oriented search engine but this
never really took off so jimmy decided
to revisit his childhood interest in
encyclopedias the idea was to create a
free-to-use online encyclopedia called
the newpedia that made money by
displaying ads
for jimmy the accuracy of the content
was extremely important so he wanted
academic experts to review all the
content before it was published on the
website and who better to hire as an
academic expert than his philosophy
friend with a phd larry in early 2000
jimmy had deliria as an editor-in-chief
and together they launched new pedia in
march of 2000 new pedia didn't just
instantly blow up though you see while
the information on newpedia was
extremely accurate no one wanted to
contribute to the site due to their
extremely rigorous approval process
jimmy had hired a bunch of highly
respected professors to review articles
on the side which was great for readers
but simply intimidated writers which
makes sense if you're writing an article
for the internet for free i'm sure you
want it to be accurate but it's not like
you want it to be graded by university
professors
so very few people from the outside
contributed which meant that most of the
articles came from jimmy and his team
jamie didn't let this discourage him
though he felt that newpedia had great
potential so he got to work on grinding
out articles but all this changed when
he started writing an article about a
noble price-winning economist named
robert c merton as you all know jamie
had a masters in finance and had years
of industry experience yet he himself
felt intimidated to write about robert
he says that it felt like writing a
doctoral thesis and he didn't even want
to do that during college when a phd was
on the line so why in the world would
anyone ever want to do this during their
free time it was clear to jimmy and
larry that the current model wouldn't
work so they decided to launch a more
casual version of new pedia called
wikipedia
neither jimmy nor larry had very high
expectations for wikipedia all of the
professors that they worked with to
dismiss the idea as something that would
never work jimmy and larry themselves
largely agreed with his viewpoint and
they were simply trying to recruit more
writers through wikipedia but to all of
their surprise wikipedia turned into
much more than just that wikipedia's
first edit came out on january 14 2001
and within just a couple of days the
number of articles on wikipedia aku
nupidia initially jimmy was super
paranoid about how wikipedia would
affect the brand image of newpedia
apparently he would wake up in the
middle of the night to read through new
submissions on wikipedia and to make
sure that they were acceptable quality
in the meantime larry was having quite a
bit of fun with wikipedia he came up
with the policies for the website which
included ignore all rules neutral point
of view no original research and
verifiability ironically though jimmy
and larry would quickly swap places you
see while larry was having a lot of fun
with wikipedia he never wanted it to
replace new pedia on the other hand
while jimmy highly prioritized accuracy
at the core he was a businessman and
wikipedia was clearly where the
opportunity was so as funding dried up
following the dot com crash jimmy pulled
the plug on newpedia in early 2002 and
went all in on wikipedia jamie no longer
wanted to find a job relating to new
pedia and larry was unwilling to switch
over to wikipedia so the duo would split
ways in march of 2002 over the next year
larry tried his best to revive new pedia
by looking for buyers and even trying to
buy it himself but when new pdf servers
crashed in september of 2003 larry knew
that that was the end of newpedia
soon after jimmy tried to monetize
wikipedia by displaying ads but this was
met with a lot of backlash from the
community it was the community that made
wikipedia what it was so why should one
organization or person reap all the
benefits jimmy didn't fight back much
and gave in pretty easily it seemed like
jimmy's main goal wasn't trying to make
a lot of money but to create something
big and influential and it was clear to
him that wikipedia was exactly that
in mid 2003 jimmy launched nonprofit
organization called the wikimedia
foundation and this nonprofit would take
over the daily operations of wikipedia
over the next couple of years wikipedia
would crush milestone after milestone
going into hundreds of thousands of
articles jimmy served as a foundation's
official chairman for a few years but in
2006 he decided that the foundation no
longer needed him he does still have a
special seat on the board called the
community founder seat but his role
today is pretty hands off since leaving
wikipedia jimmy has primarily spent his
time on other community oriented
projects in 2012 for instance he was an
advisor to the uk government helping to
make taxpayer-funded research freely
available on the internet similarly in
2017 he launched an online publication
called wiki tribune which was dedicated
to fighting biased news and in 2019 he
launched an ad free social network
called wiki tribune social in the
meantime larry has grown more and more
distant from wikipedia in fact he has
actually become a major critic of
wikipedia and has regularly made
comments that discredit the site he
tried to launch a competitor to
wikipedia called citizen dm in 2006. it
drew on the community nature of
wikipedia but also had more checks in
place to ensure credibility
unfortunately citizen dm never took off
but larry also never gave up for example
between 2008 and 2010 he worked on the
watch now learn project which attempted
to create a repository of educational
videos for kids similarly in 2013 he
launched a crowdsource news portal
called infobit and in december of 2017
he launched everpedia which was once
again a more credible version of
wikipedia but based on the blockchain
you just have to take one look at the
all-time graph of the everpedia token to
see how that turned out despite all
these failures larry still hasn't quit
in trying to create an antithesis to
wikipedia in october of 2019 for
instance he launched encyclosphere.org
at the end of the day the truth is that
most of larry's criticisms about the
credibility of wikipedia are true and
fair but it seems like larry has never
been able to look past that and see the
bright side of wikipedia which is truly
quite a shame jimmy however was able to
see wikipedia for exactly what it was
and i think he says it best he estimates
that wikipedia is worth at least three
billion dollars a day so by donating
wikipedia to the foundation you could
say that he lost out on three billion
dollars but he also strongly believes
that if he didn't donate wikipedia it
wouldn't be worth three billion today so
donating the site will forever be the
dumbest and smartest decision of his
life do you guys have a positive or
negative opinion on wikipedia comment
that down below also drop a like if
wikipedia carried you on an exam and of
course consider checking out our
international channels to watch your
videos in other languages and consider
subscribing to see more questions
logically answered but until then i'm
ari and i'll see you guys on the next
one
you